Film Courage: If someone comes to you and
says “Hey I have this great script that
I wrote.
How do I get a studio to make it?
Adam, please…I know you work in Hollywood
or you know people in Hollywood, can I get
this script to you?”
Writer/Director/Actor, Adam Cushman: What
do I say?
I mean it depends, it’s situational.
I mean it depends.
It depends on the conversation, what type
of movie it is and everything else.
I read a lot but beyond that if you’re asking
me when filmmakers come to me and they’re
like “How do I get this made?”
Film Courage: “I need Hollywood to make
it.
If they see it, it’s going to be the next
(fill in the blank).”
Adam: This almost always comes with them attached
to play the lead.
In which case…since that is most cases I
usually say I think you should consider finding
a way to go make your film and make it on
your terms.
It’s just not 1978 anymore…I mean I wish
it was but it’s not and the days of sitting
in a coffee shop chewing your nails waiting
on a deal is not realistic.
It’s not going to happen that way.
So I would say try if you can get any traction
that way, terrific.
But look at what’s out there and if that
person is saying I want a studio to make my
film for 40-50 million dollars, I want to
be in theaters say look what is in theaters
though.
Is there anything like what you’re doing
right now?
And that’s not to discourage people from
making the film but I would say find a way
to go make it your way because they are going
to try and take it away from you anyway and
they’re going to have weird ideas and take
it in their own direction but that’s my
advice.
Like I think we’re just living in an era
where you just have to go do it and it’s
easier than ever.
I mean look at John Cassavetes and look at
all the great…he’s the bar.
He is what we alway refer to as the person
who went out and did it and he shot on film
and they had lab fees and we don’t have
that.
I mean we can have that but we also have the
Alexas and the Red cameras and this technology
where we can go shoot now.
So there is just no excuse.
Film Courage: What if they say “I am not
in Hollywood.
I’m in a state that there is no industry
here?”
Adam: Dude, even better.
Everyone’s going to want to help you.
I mean seriously everyone is going to want
to be…not everyone but people are going
to want to help in the community because they
want to help you succeed.
They’ve never seen a film done before.
It’s interesting, it’s novel.
I found it much easier to shoot outside of
Los Angeles.
You know, here I went to a burger place (it’s
the one next to Paramount Pictures because
I had a scene at the place).
And I went in the morning and I talked to
the guy and he was “The Guy” and I’m
like “Bare bones, indie film, I would need
like three hours, I would come during off
hours, no problem.
Even night is fine, I can fake it for the
day.”
He’s like “Yeah, $20,000.”
I’m like “Copy that.”
It’s where you are.
There are people who will pay that and that
is a thing so I think if you’re living outside
of LA, it’s a benefit and you can get a
lot more mileage out of whatever you’re
doing.”
Film Courage: And you shot RESTRAINT [one
of Adam’s films] where?
Adam: Predominantly in Apple Valley.
Film Courage: Is that San Bernardino County
[California]?
Adam: I think so.
It’s high desert.
And that was like that too.
We found that to be the case.
Our producer was from there so we had certain
resources but that not withstanding it was
a very inexpensive permit and they were very
open to us shooting throughout the city and
different areas, gas stations, cleaners, parks,
things like that.
And they were just very helpful.
Film Courage: Who did you contact to get that
permit?
Did they have a film office?
Adam: Yes, the producer did that but I think
we got it out of necessity.
We were shooting at a house and then someone
from the city stopped by and was like “Do
you guys have a permit?”
I’m like “Do we need it for the house?”
And he’s like “Yes.
You can keep going, don’t worry about it
but you need to get that.”
I was like Wow!
Here they would shut you down and take your
memory card and make an example out of you.
But you go one hour outside of LA and they’re
just ultra helpful.
Question For The Viewers: What advice do you
have for someone who wants Hollywood to make
their movie?